hey guys it's max welcome to our
step-by-step easy build guide on how you
can put together this $492 fort night
gaming PC even if you've never built a
PC before I'm gonna show you exactly
which parts I chose why and then how to
set up the system and I have all the
parts linked in the video description
along with some alternative parts if one
of these are out of stock or if you have
a little bit more money to spend now
along with the fortnight video that we
put out which you guys can check out by
clicking this card above I also made a
video on how this thing handles 4k video
editing so if you want to see that
there's gonna be a link in the video
description so if you like those videos
make sure you hit that subscribe button
and enable those notifications so you
guys don't miss out on future videos
which we have a lot of great videos
coming so for this video we had two main
goals first is to keep this under a
certain budget under $500 so that almost
anybody could afford it even if you're
just getting into PC gaming and the
second one was getting competitive
levels of performance and fortnight at
1080p so we can get a solid 60 FPS while
having good graphics quality and we did
achieve this now I'm gonna go over all
of these parts once again so they're
linked in the video description and at
the heart of the build we have this
Intel i3 processor it's an HN CPU that
is quad core with really good per core
performance at a very great price point
so this thing is really kind of the best
entry-level CPU and 4 cores is all that
you really need right now for gaming and
even if you buy a more expensive
graphics card this thing won't be a
bottleneck next up I'm gonna start off
with our graphics card here and we chose
the rx 560 because of the price point
that it comes in in the level of
performance that it offers now if you
have a little bit more cash the first
thing that I would upgrade for gaming is
the graphics card even though this does
give us really great performance for the
money
I would probably upgrade to the nvidia
1060 and that will really take it up to
the next level if you have some room in
your budget now let's move on to our SSD
now this wasn't the cheapest thing I
could choose I could have gotten a
standard SSD but I really liked the
convenience of having a m2 you just plug
it in put one screw in and that's it so
it's nice and convenient and it's also
fast and nice for gaming when you're
loading in next up we have our RAM and
this is 8 gigabyte
of ddr4 2666 megahertz ram and if you're
gonna be doing a video editing PC and
you have a little bit more money I would
upgrade this to 16 gigabytes but for
gaming 8 gigabytes is enough and I chose
this one specifically because of the
price point now on to the power supply
we have a 500 watt white Edition power
supply I mainly chose this because of
the price point and a lot of people
overspent on their power supplies you
really don't even need this much for
this build I've actually used this power
supply three separate times or this is
the third time performs great and it's
going to be plenty so I rather spend
more money on other parts now let's talk
about the motherboard I decided to spend
a little bit more money than I had to to
get this motherboard because they had
some extra features including for RAM
slots a lot of the less expensive
motherboards only have two so if you get
a dual channel kit like the one we chose
out you're gonna be stuck to just eight
gigs of ram unless you want to replace
all of your RAM so I definitely thought
it was worth spending a little bit more
money and getting something a little bit
higher end hey guys it's max from the
future I just want to let you know that
I somehow ordered an older version of
that motherboard we did get the newer
version and it looks almost identical so
keep following the build guide
everything's gonna be matching up
perfectly just make sure you ordered the
one from the link in the video
description so you get the new gen
version not the older one and finally we
have our cooler master case now I chose
this for a few reasons this is actually
the second time I'm building with it
it's fairly easy to build with
especially for this price point so it
comes in in our budget but it also looks
really cool as well you don't want to
get something that's cheap looking and
kind of boring so we have a full acrylic
side window which is tinted and we also
have these thumb screws here so it makes
it easy to take the panel off and along
with that you can actually swap out
these little inserts here so you can
change up the color so for this price
point I really like this case so like I
said at the start I have a full list of
parts in the video description along
with some alternatives if you have a
little bit more money and some extra
accessories and peripherals if you want
to pick those up as well including some
monitor options so let's get right into
the build alright guys we're gonna start
off working with a motherboard I like to
set it on top of the motherboard box so
you don't damage any of the soldering
points at the back and we're gonna start
out by installing the m2 SSD but to do
that we need to open up our side panel
and take out the little hardware box on
the inside which has the screw so
actually inside this box are the inserts
to change the colors on the front panel
so we don't need those but imma grab
this little baggie and this is where
we're gonna have all the screws that
we're gonna need so there's a lot of
different screws in here but we need the
one that is really small with the flat
top there's two of them including here
but we're only going to use one so let's
grab our m2 SSD and we're gonna insert
it at an angle it only goes in one way
so you don't force it in typically it's
with the sticker facing the top and
actually I just noticed that it that
comes with the screw on the motherboard
a lot of motherboards a lot more
expensive ones don't have one inserted
already so I'm gonna pull this out grab
a little screwdriver here once again
push it in an angle press it down
line up you'll screw here and make sure
not to over tighten it because we
already have a good connection next
let's install our CPU I'm going to start
off by opening up this little tray here
and you just have to pull this bar down
and it's going to open up like this and
when you're taking your CPU out of the
little plastic case don't touch the top
of it you don't wanna get your oils from
your fingers on it and mess up your
thermal performance so grab it by the
edges and on the CPU there's a little
triangle at the bottom left hand side
and that matches up with the triangle on
the socket and for this we just want to
carefully drop it in here
don't force it in align it and it should
drop right in keep the cover up on the
top I'm gonna push this down and it the
little tray actually locks into this
screw on the motherboard and as you
press down this little cover will pop
off now let's install the CPU cooler for
this one I'm just using the included
Intel cooler
I do have an alternative that is fairly
inexpensive linked in the video
description and I would suggest getting
that and it has its own installation
guide for this one it's very easy to
install which is good you literally just
set it on top
don't touch the thermal paste align all
these little pins with the holes on the
motherboard try not to move it around a
lot once you set it down and we're
really just gonna push down on all four
of these corners and they just clip in
there we go and then now I'm gonna take
this little cable out and I'm gonna plug
it into the CPU fan section let's plug
it in and when you plug in a lot of
these connectors you can only do them
one way and has a little locking pin now
I'm going to install the RAM you can't
do this afterwards when the motherboard
is inside of the case you might have an
easier time screwing down your
motherboard without the RAM inserted but
it's easier to show you guys how to
properly do it when the motherboard is
out here we just have two sticks so for
this motherboard you're gonna insert it
into the second slot and the fourth slot
so you want to pay attention if you have
a different one check your motherboards
manual we're gonna start off by opening
up these little clips on each side and
on your RAM sticks you have this cutout
here and its offset so you can only put
it in one way and they're gonna apply
some force on one corner and then the
other and it's gonna click in if it's
not going in make sure you have a align
properly so let's do the second one
there we go now we're going to get the
case ready for our motherboard and all
those components I'm going to set that
off to the side I'm gonna start off with
removing the rear panel here after that
we're gonna install our i/o shield which
is going to cover up all the empty spots
for our inputs and outputs for this one
you want these three little cutouts for
the audio to be at the bottom and then
our ps2 port and USBs at the top now
with that installed we have to screw in
our standoff standoffs look like this
they're included with your case and
they're meant to support and hold up the
motherboard so as you guys can see here
we have six different cutouts for the
screws and that's what we have to
install in the case it's pretty easy in
this case they're just these ones right
here six of them on the left-hand side
I'm going to start off by just hand
threading them and then using the
standoff tool to tighten it down all the
way so it won't unscrew later if you
take out your the motherboard now we're
going to insert our motherboard do you
want to pay attention to where the
cutouts are it's gonna sit on the
standoffs and just do this carefully
take your time you don't want to scratch
the bottom on those standoffs you're
gonna drop it in and then pay special
attention so that all your little inputs
and outputs line up to the i/o shield
here and then a couple the standoffs
actually have little risers so lock in
here
now we're gonna use six of these
included screws to hold down the
motherboard take your time and just
don't over tighten it now we're going to
install our power supply so I'm going to
grab it here this case does have a
filter at the bottom so we want the fan
to be facing the bottom and I'm gonna
try to grab this bundle of wires here
and pull it through the back side we're
gonna align it towards the back and
inside the power supply box we have
these four included screws I'm gonna
push the power supply against the case
and right where you see the threads for
the screws you'll screw this thing down
now we have a bunch of wires here we're
not going to be using all of them and
I'm going to show you where to route the
different ones and which ones we do and
don't need this guy needs to go to this
top right corner there's not enough room
through here with this case so I'm going
to drop it and push it through this
little section right here now the next
one we need is going to be this 24 pin
it's the thickest set of wires with a
bunch of connectors this one's going to
go into this slot in the middle here and
then for our graphics card we have this
set right here that says PCIe for PCI
Express we're going to push this one
through this section right over here the
lower one and then all of these cables
right here we don't need if you're gonna
install a standard hard drive in here
with a lot more space you're going to
need these or if you're gonna have some
other kind of accessories but I'm just
going to bundle these back up now we
also have these cables that are included
with the case they're all ran through
one section and I'm gonna do this a
little bit different just we have a
cleaner set up this largest one with a
bunch of pans is four USB 3.0 I'm going
to run this one through the same as our
24 pin this slot right here and here we
have all of our system connectors and
this one right here is labeled USB and
this one's probably going to be our
audio yep they're all labeled on here
I'm going to round these through the
bottom here right where we have our
power supply that way we have a cleaner
set up now let's flip the key surround
set it down and start connecting we're
gonna start off with our eight pin CPU
connector on the back we have these
little clips so this is how you know
which way it goes in we're going to line
it up right here at the top left hand
side
bend this down and now we're going to
connect our 24 pin and you're gonna have
to hold this little addition to it I'm
going to bend it down and it's gonna
plug into that large slot there with our
actual locks on this side here now we're
going to do our USB 3 connection there's
a little pin there so it will only go
one way it's going to line it up take
your time then now let's connect the
front audio and front USB these only go
in one way so make sure you take your
time and the little label on it on these
pins face down towards the power supply
and now let's connect the power switch
the reset and the led these have labels
for positive and negatives and on the
motherboard it lists that as well so
just take your time line it up if there
is no label I typically use this little
arrow to connect towards positive now
let's connect the case fan this is going
to plug in right above the CPU where we
have that power connector the connector
on the fan is a three pin when we have
four coming out of the motherboard so
you want to keep this towards the right
side and the lock will only go in one
way this case only comes with one case
fan but there's also room for two more
up front and that's very easy to install
I'm gonna link in the video description
to cheap case fans along with case fans
that I really like for a little bit more
money I'll show you guys just how to pop
this panel off there's little clips on
the back but you don't really have to
push down on them it actually comes off
fairly easy just apply some pressure at
the bottom and it will pop right off and
then you're gonna align the case fans
from the rear and screw them in in these
little screw points with the screws that
are included in and then at the end
we're gonna plug them into some of these
extra connectors that we didn't end up
using and now it's time for the graphics
card we're gonna start off with
unscrewing these top two PCI slot covers
and we're gonna want to keep these
little screws because they're gonna hold
down our graphics card and now we're
going to take off the little PCI slot
cover on the graphics card and this
little section right here is going to
slide in right in between the case and
the motherboard so be careful when
you're inserting it we want to take our
time align our connectors to the
motherboard
and evenly kind of press down and you'll
notice that it actually locks in place
now we can grab our screwdriver and
reinstall these little screws so as I
was installing this graphics card I
actually noticed that there are no
additional power connectors that are
needed for this I guess it's been a
while since I've built such a budget
build most of the graphics cards do need
additional power but this one draws
enough power through the motherboard
connector so if you are going to be
upgrading to a higher-end graphics card
you will need these additional powers
power cables here and they plug in just
the same way as everything else it only
goes in one way I'm gonna go ahead and
tuck it back in along with all those
extra cables and lastly I'm gonna spend
a little bit of time doing some cable
management I'm going to pull out this
power cable we didn't use pull out some
of the excess slack in some of these
other cables just to make it look a
little bit nicer you can use some of the
zip ties that are included in your case
tie everything down to these included
little slots and then put the side
panels back on alright okay so I set up
the monitor keyboard mouse plug that in
I'm gonna I plug the power supply cable
in make sure it's on the set to the on
position let's power it on and sometimes
you got to turn it on and off a few
times if it's a brand new system
nothing's installed to make sure that
everything shows up properly if it
doesn't you could try to connect to the
actual motherboard instead of the
graphics card
sometimes there's issues but right now
we are connected via HDMI to the
graphics card and if you can't get it to
boot you can also try to take the
graphics card out and just connect to
the motherboard because it does have
integrated graphics so let me hit I
don't know which button we need but
maybe f2 or f8 on the screen it was
showing to select a proper boot media if
you go over here to the side we're gonna
see our CPR temps 39 which is great and
we also show eight gigs of ram so
everything is displaying properly I'm
gonna move over here to the peripherals
and our initial display output is set to
PCIe one this should be by default
meaning it's our dedicated graphics card
not the built-in one and now we should
be good we see our SSD that showed up so
I'm gonna just go to
save and exit settings now we're going
to install windows I'm not going to show
you how to create the actual USB it's
super easy this is a 32 gigabyte 2 USB
3.0 I'm gonna have a link to Microsoft's
website where you can download the USB
windows creation tool it's step-by-step
very easy you don't have to have a
license key to actually download it and
even to set up windows and be able to
use Windows you don't have to have a key
anymore so I'm gonna grab this plug it
into a USB 3.0 slot that's one of the
blue ones and then I'm gonna hit save
and exit so it's still not grabbing that
USB key unfortunately this time when
we're gonna restart I'm gonna hit f12
which is the Craig button to select what
you want to boot from okay so here we
have our menu and I'm going to select
UEFI Samsung flash drive partition one
out of the list
and there you go we have that familiar
little Windows logo and here this is
very easy it's also step by step and
here if you have a product key you can
go ahead and enter it or you can just
hit I don't have a product key and
surprisingly Microsoft will now let you
install and use Windows pretty much as
long as you want with just a little logo
on the corner saying that it's not
activated I'm just gonna select the home
option here we're gonna select the
custom install windows only select your
SSD or your drive hit new apply and ok
so that's gonna format your SSD or your
hard drive and after it's formatted all
we just hit next and there we go
now we're gonna be installing Windows it
doesn't take too long for it to do so as
soon as Windows 10 is finished
installing you're gonna get to setup
your computer name sign in or create a
Microsoft account and then you're gonna
land on the desktop so I don't need to
show you guys that it's just like if you
were to buy one from the store after
that I would suggest connecting to the
internet and then downloading the latest
drivers for your graphics card and then
allowing Windows Update to do its thing
make sure you have all the latest
drivers and security updates stuff like
that so that part of it is very simple
and then you can download fortnight or
any other games that you have or video
editing software so if you guys did not
see our fortnight video or a 4k video
editing you guys will be able to use the
links in the description or use the end
cards once again you guys can check the
description for all the parts along with
alternatives and different suggestions
on peripherals fans for this system and
then if you guys want to overclock the
CPU or set the RAM timing higher you
guys can definitely do that I'm not
going to show you how there's lots of
videos on YouTube but I will say if
you're gonna do some overclocking on the
CPU definitely get that suggested CPU
cooler instead of using the built in or
included one with the Intel CPU so thank
you guys for watching make sure you guys
are subscribed and you guys have those
notifications enabled so you guys don't
miss out on future videos we're gonna
have more builds coming up in the future
along with a lot of other great
interesting videos this has been a max
and I will see you in the next video